nabila a été interviewé par le magazine
quotidien
c'est ça alors dans la voiture parce que
vous étiez avec 2001 mais ce match
laisse ma vie mais je crois que vous
nous suiviez sur sa wii donc j'y suis
avec avec nabil donc vous avez vous avez
participé à l'interview alors eh bien
regardez ce qu'on a vu dans quotidien et
on a aussi vu beaucoup de chance de
croiser nabila très bien pour définir le
festival de cannes
trop bien trop stylé on aime trop td est
ressentiment alors c'est dans le style
de nabila sympathique un pas beaucoup de
mots assez assez assez expressif
alors en fait ils n'ont pas tout montrer
quotidien en fait voilà ce qu elle avait
réellement 20 voilà ce qu'elle avait dit
en entier
regardez déjà
non c'est bien la voiture bonsoir qui
secoue prête à cannes et écoutez je
cherche à cyril serré la main il nous a
donné rendez vous qu'on ne sait pas
oublié d'accord vous allez voir des
films je suis à peut-être démarches et
efforts star wars avec les étoiles et
ont donc coupé ya eu quelques coups bien
spolié le film en tout cas au qui nous
donne toujours quotidien qui donne
toujours des grandes leçons de
déontologie de journalisme etc
dès que ça les arrange pas il coupe
alors qu'ils sont les premiers à
chercher la petite bête toujours à
débusquer les os et c'est là je trouve
que c'est pas très propre
si vous me permettez voilà non ce n'est
pas à d'autres enquêtes c'est une façon
de faire du journalisme qui leur à
partir est particulière mois là on va
passer à l'autre info du jour qui se
marient qui